oh wait welcome to see your play and
beat so after some know while we
actually get a banker again overall 92o
forgotten I have forgotten the precise
line against it
I think it's actually wrong what am i
doing the answers okay after after check
it this B 3 B should be to set up yeah I
have stumbled right into what why the
ones what do i do against 92 actually
yeah yeah I always hate this way forget
what's right and I actually know what's
right but forget it what do I play
against this you don't know that each
like a g6 maybe or something takes you
four be six maybe I have to look that up
this this kind of position is normally
better for wide and yeah maybe this is
also the case here it's not like I mean
it doesn't feel like I'm in huge trouble
but i am i'm certainly not completely em
out of the woods here what hurts what
happens our 292 takes you for I know
that takes e4 c3 is a line but I don't
think I recommended that I think I play
is six you have to check it yeah but
should be seven it's not a usual only
good position here from all the bishop
but I want to be ready to play to take
on d5 if he goes a five
Tim think this is kind of okay for black
it's maybe a slight edge for white due
to space but it doesn't feel clock
doesn't feel critical or anything he's
got this long diagonal issue issue set
up set up Oh trading this is strongly
okay I mean his bishop is on the light
squares many porns light squares maybe
maybe I can do something with the carpet
that I mean it's not anything serious at
a wallet yes okay and I really don't
want to allow the night population only
six to get to one so what's going on
here five
I go 97 he might play we should be five
hmm how to do the same McQueen it's hard
to get anything going here with with can
put the Queen you five tix it takes on
these six and it's 3d dangerous okay
come on i put this back he might have
been shot before I've and take it or
something like that but I'm more
concerned about you five here at the
moment
think I played six in the opening I'm
still kind of still kind of annoyed that
I have forgotten how to play this
because the way I played it is really
not precise yes so you want to take her
no doesn't want to take Queen before is
that I get the night to see fire it's
difficult to say if I if this is fine or
not really really difficult okay come on
let's do it could be entirely wrong
really to do this the default porn I'm
not really sure this is a weakness or
not I like to get the square here of
course there probably is a weakness okay
so if I here and I've no
okay thats goood see if 94 I'm crazy I
never killed okay before was hanging
with it might still be possible I come
wow I did not see that see final very
bad are crazy crazy King III after and
that was terrible but Evelyn he was
really bad so he has calculated all this
probably this this d6 Hanks is the thing
time morning Wow and plate is so
terribly amazing this is blundering it
composition was perfectly okay ready and
I managed to give it away very very
simply
check check find a million chicks in
check I really discussed it the other
day how I played this check very good
player ja place is very nicely
technically speaking check check check
check game drawn really disgusted hear
what I did I mean here I think it's not
that much going on and engine kind of
agrees with that was really bad Jeff
Queen Queen before as one of those
decisions where you really at least I
have no clear idea if it's good or not I
mean maybe the beep on is just getting
too weak but what's what if 5 f-5 is
unspeakably bad I totally did not
recognize that these sixes basically
gone
oh okay yeah we can still go f5 which is
interesting at least and then probably
also not good but this is just yuck I
mean okay that it with a deep on maybe
but the general idea is just terrible
and T I'm just completely completely
toast yeah just I think I think I play
me sucks here yeah II success is what I
do right like this then takes two x plus
6 yeah there should be two 1976 okay i
think i played this I was really this is
the quite okay for white yeah why does a
little bit of an advantage in this
position the way it turned out I think I
equalized but then then I killed myself
in this ending that was really bad oh
wow ok thanks for watching